[Music]
seventy-two Megan you beat him it's like
the mathematics of like eyes to nose to
mouth to head with height ratio
delivered on Stern and they were saying
that like Brad Pitt it's like a 92 or
something no oh so it actually does bear
out if you pointed it at George Clooney
or I guess yeah your head is close to
the perfect ratio Megan your eyes are
nearly the perfect distance apart
they're slightly too small for your head
I'm always saying that it's kind of
gross you have a slightly narrow mouth
for your face you got things just saying
what we've all been thinking yeah you
scared no one scared I know this isn't
gonna go well I was a 45 I think they're
way too big for your hand error okay
smoke is coming out of your top now
there's only so much I can do I was
designed by the Greeks
I'll make the Parthenon the old Golden
Rule it says I look a lot like Conan
O'Brien congratulations
Oh usually that's a curse
[Music]